لا أعلم أن اللاعبين قد لمسوه
الكثير من الناس من المغرب أيضًا
هذه هي القضايا الاجتماعية ، كما تعلمون هناك
الناس طفل حسناً أعتقد ذلك
اليوم لا ينبغي أن نفعل أكثر من ذلك
18 19 سنة من العمر ربما 20 أو نعم
يبلغ من العمر 25 عامًا ، وهو طفل ، وسوف يفعل ذلك أيضًا
التعلم من هذا الموضوع الآن الشبكات
الاجتماعية هناك أطفال فقدوا
في بعض الأحيان هناك عنصرية في الحياة ولكن أنا
أعتقد أن العنصرية اجتماعية أكثر منها
بقي من الولد الصالح الذي سيتعلم
لا أريد أن أجعل الموضوع بعد الآن
لأنه ولد له حياة
بعد ذلك لا أريد قتله نحن
المسلمون وفي منطقتنا
تعلمنا أن نغفر لذلك دعونا
اغفر لهذا الطفل الذي يتعلم من هذا
الموضوع وأنه يبقى وربما سيعطي
قدوة للآخرين بأننا شعب
متواضع كما تعلم وهو موضوع انسكب منه
المسلمون لا يوجد هذا أفضل
مثال يمكننا أن نظهر ونغفر
سأخبر هذا الطفل أنه صنع واحدة
نقص والتعلم من ذلك وانظر ماذا
ما رأيك في المسلمين ليس جيدا
أن نسامح ونمضي قدمًا